[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  where are the protests I don't see any  protests I will shortly leave the job  that it has been the honor of my life to  hold I do so with no ill-will but with  enormous and enduring gratitude to have  had the opportunity to serve the country  I love good afternoon I have just been  to see her majesty the queen who has  invited me to form a government and I  have accepted  [Music]  how would you characterize the Malheur  investigation politically-motivated we  went through the greatest witch hunt in  political history I'm announcing the  House of Representative in forward with  an official impeachment inquiry  good luck Rosa we demand that you take  your responsibilities and do something  [Music]  you